foreign
he says that he doesn't need to show up
and answer questions to the prosecutor
instead the prosecutor should be
answering his questions and that he
remains the judicial investigator and
that he will not step down until he
issues an indictment
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
with this release they killed us again
they had killed our brothers and now
they killed those of us who are still
alive
this is a decision to run away from law
because they are the ones accused the
Lebanese state is the one accused of the
Beirut Port blast
we see this as really a battle for
lebanon's future are we going to have a
kind of country where those individuals
who are responsible for blowing up the
country are held accountable or one
where they're allowed to escape
accountability it's a very complicated
legal situation but the political
establishment the ruling establishment
are doing everything that they can to
prevent judgment retired from moving
forward with the investigation they are
doing everything that they can to
prevent the truth from coming out and
for those high-level officials
responsible for the blast to be held to
account
[Music]